It's no secret there's
lots of money to be made
owning a sports team.
Media deals and fan enthusiasm soaring,
it's been really hard not to make money.
Now, with more cash than ever
vying for a place in pro sports
and a reckoning around equality
and opportunity underway,
the biggest payday may be on
the women's side of the game.
Alex Morgan!
I look at the women's sports market
similar to venture.
There's a lot more upside.
Woo! How'd that go in?
Female athletes and fans
have been trailblazing this
change for generations.
Historically, and more recently,
it's been a painful process
as women fight institutions and systems
seemingly designed to diminish and,
even at times, abuse them.
It's not just a basic
issue of right and wrong,
but also a question about power and money,
and the conversation around
how to invest in women's sports
and who is writing the checks
has taken on a different
urgency and dimension,
perhaps leading to a new
and very lucrative era
of opportunity.
Imagine if you had a
chance to go back in time
and by the Boston Celtics in 1957.
If you make the investment now,
given how low franchise prices are,
I would expect, in 20, 25 years,
your investment's gonna
be worth, you know,
many, many times what
you just paid for it.
So, we're here in Los Angeles,
on a freeway, naturally.
This is one of the great sports towns,
some of the most notable
franchises across all sports.
You think about the Lakers,
you think about the Dodgers.
Everyone seems, though,
to be talking about the
newest team on the scene,
and that's Angel City.
The Women's soccer team
is coming to Los Angeles, all
thanks to Natalle Portman.
Angel City FC is the product
of actress and activist Natalle Portman
and Kara Nortman,
a partner at an early
stage investment firm.
They made headlines last year
when they announced plans
to bring in national women's
soccer league team to LA.
Their star-studded list of investors
includes Jennifer
Garner, Jessica Chastain,
America Ferrera,
Uzo Aduba, and Eva Longoria.
The leading founding
investor is Alexis Ohanian.
He's the co-founder of Reddit,
and, of course, the
husband to Serena Williams.
Their toddler daughter,
Alexis Olympia Ohanian,
is also an investor.
They brought in a third
co-founder to run the team,
a veteran of building businesses.
Her name is Julie Uhrman,
and right now, she's still
building out their office space.
So, this is a real startup.
I mean,
we're still waiting for Fiverr.
Hi! How are you? Good to see you!
Yeah, this is the future
home of Angel City.
So, we've got two big
conference rooms here.
Then we'll call this the bullpen,
for lack of a better term right now.
I have to start using
more soccer references
than other sports.
What's really neat with this blank wall
is we'll have a projector
so we can project games on the wall,
but we're gonna have pull-down,
so we'll have a pull down green screen,
pull down widescreen, and
a pull-down step and repeat
so that we can do content
shoots here, merch shoots here.
When we have player signings,
we can just create the atmosphere here.
Uhrman's a native Angelino
who came up through media and technology
and has a knack for
getting into businesses
at points of inflection.
I was an entrepreneur in college.
My stepfather was an entrepreneur.
You know, he taught us
two things growing up.
The first was work for yourself
and be in control of your own destiny,
and, if you can't work for yourself,
be on the revenue side of the business.
While valuations have continued to rise
in a lot of sports,
this is a tough business in many ways,
and it's an especially tough business
when it comes to
professional women's sports.
This is not for the faint
of heart, in many ways.
Over 90% of all sports teams
globally don't make money,
and so, we looked at all
this information and said,
"We're female founders, that's different.
We're gonna raise money
like it's a startup,
which is different.
We're gonna drive to profitability
'cause if we can show we can make money
being different in those other ways,
that's gonna be pretty significant."
Julie Uhrman sent me a LinkedIn message,
and was just like, "Hey,
I hear you're the woman
to talk to in sponsorship,
and I'd love to talk
to you about an idea."
This is Jess Smith.
She's the head of revenue for Angel City,
and her idea was to blend
Angel City's goal of profit
with social impact.
I put together a business
proposal for her,
and said, "Hey, this is how I think
you should go to market,"
and it was really that, if
you're gonna walk in a room
and tell people that
you're standing for change,
how do you hold yourself accountable,
and also, the partner accountable,
and really, the way to do
that is through dollars.
When we started talking to brands,
we also launched the Angel
City sponsorship model,
where we give 10% of
our sponsorship dollars
back into the community through
our social impact platform.
So, when Angel City
sells their front of kit
sponsorship to Door Dash,
10% of that sale goes
to combating food
insecurity in Los Angeles.
This purpose driven advertising
has helped to attract the
likes of Birdies, Heineken,
Tecate, and Gatorade.
We said from the beginning
we wanted to build an organization
where mission to capital could coexist,
so what does that mean?
It means that we want to
set higher expectations.
What does that mean, right?
It means that we lead
with passion and purpose
to drive to profitability,
and that is the key sentence
that we make decisions
based on every single day.
Recently though,
Angel City's impact in the world of sports
would take on an added importance.
The national women's soccer league
faces a reckoning overcharges
that it ignored abuse
of its players.
Former NWSL players have
accused former coach Paul Riley
of sexual coercion.
A stark reminder of just how backwards
and broken parts of the system are
came in late September,
when The Athletic
published an investigation
detailing allegations
of sexual misconduct,
including harassment and coerced sex.
It also detailed how earlier accusations
weren't fully investigated
or disciplined by the league.
Our institution failed
us, the system, right?
It's the people in power,
not just the coach,
but the leadership team.
Paul Riley couldn't be
reached for comment,
and has denied the allegations.
The league suspended play for the weekend
after The Athletic report published,
and forced the resignation of
the commissioner, Lisa Baird.
She said in a statement
that she takes full responsibility
for her role in the allegations
and is sorry for the
pain many are feeling.
Social media was filled
with indignation and anger,
including from Megan
Rapinoe, who tweeted, quote,
burn it all down.
Let all their heads roll.
I hope we're in a real moment of reckoning
where we can turn this into real change
and hopefully save the league,
'cause, as it stands right now,
that's not really league any
of us wanna be a part of.
Angel City may be part of that change.
Sinead Farrelly whose
allegations of long-term abuse
were detailed in The Athletic
cited Angel City as part of
her inspiration to go public.
I think I started reading the article
at 5:15 in the morning, Pacific time,
and I don't think I've ever done this,
but I was in and out of tears all day.
This is Angela Hucles,
a two time gold medalist for US soccer
and founding investor for Angel City.
This is something that affects all of us.
It doesn't just affect
the soccer community.
This is something that
we are struggling with
in our society and the world,
and this is something
that we need to get right.
US Soccer Federation
which governs the NWSL
retained former deputy
attorney general Sally Yates
to lead an investigation into the league
as it hopes to rebuild
its trust with players.
For me, and, I think, our organization
and that we're continuing
to do on the daily
its to make sure that
we are moving forward
and providing a better environment
and a place that is stronger
than it's ever been before,
to make sure that these women can play,
and be celebrated, and feel safe,
and that's not an
unacceptable thing to ask for.
The harsh reality for the NWSL
is not only does it need
to regain the support
and trust of its players,
but it will also need time to develop
its fan and sponsor base.
And if it's looking for a role model,
look no further than the WNBA.
Reiner finds Taurasi at three!
It's gone! She got it!
The GOAT delivers again!
At 25 years old,
the league is one of the
oldest, most well-known,
and most successful women's
sports leagues in the world.
And its stars are getting
more attention than ever.
Whether it's from activism
efforts around the league,
or more blue chip advertisers
featuring them in commercials.
I sold a car to Sue Bird.
11 all-star appearances. Can you imagine?
I mean, I'm working on it.
But if you measure the
WNBA against the NBA,
it's still a massive gap.
Attendance for the NBA averages
more than 17,000 a game,
while the WNBA averages
between six and 7,000,
and estimates of the
combined revenue for the NBA,
it's about $7.9 billion
versus the WNBA at 60 million.
I think the big issue people
have with women's sports
is that, relative to men's
sports, it's a lot smaller.
This is David Berry.
He's a professor who's written extensively
about the economics of sports,
especially women's sports,
and he argues that the biggest factor
between men and women's leagues is time.
WNBA is smaller because
it's only 25 years old,
and, if you look at the NBA
when it was 25 years old,
it looks a lot like the WNBA today.
The NBA back in the late 1960s
was getting about six, 7,000 fans a game.
Nobody really paid much
attention to the league,
and, in 25, 30 years,
WNBA's gonna look a lot like the NBA.
As David explains, this
decades long growth
has been true in almost all pro sports.
It usually takes generations
to develop emotional attachment to teams.
Take the Pittsburgh Steelers
who were purchased by Art Rooney in 1933
for a whopping $53,000 in today's dollars.
Art Rooney is investing in a sports league
where 85 to 90% of the previous franchises
completely went out of business,
but he does it anyways.
He loves football, so he puts
his money into this thing.
For 40 years, Rooney kept putting money
into a Steelers franchise
that won nothing.
They went to one playoff game at 40 years,
and, in that playoff game,
they scored no points.
He never saw a playoff point for 40 years,
and he kept putting money into it.
Eventually, a fan base develops,
people become emotionally attached to it,
and the Steelers that are
inherited by his grandson
are worth a billion dollars.
And nearly two decades later,
Art Rooney II's franchise
is worth $3.4 billion.
Ownership is an area Angel
City thinks it can improve on.
Instead of having its future rest
on the shoulders of one owner,
it instead has a diversified ownership
across a large group,
including an all-star
list of former players.
We're but budding seeds,
except, this time, we're owners!
It started in an email, really.
Julie Foudy, Mia Hamm sent to the rest
of some of the players
about this opportunity
to invest in Angel City
and bringing women's professional
soccer to Los Angeles.
I think it was probably
the quickest response
that I've seen from
about, you know, 10 women.
And that ownership group would only grow.
We have over 60 owners.
They're all incredible.
They all bring something
different to the platform.
I was telling someone the other day
that I literally don't
think there is an owner
that hasn't done something for Angel City.
The story I've told in
some rooms about that
is being in a sponsorship
pitch, talking to a beer brand,
and a gentleman's in the room.
He says, "Hey, I'm from the
lifestyle side of the brand,
and, candidly, I don't follow sports,
but I have to tell you,
I know everything about Angel City
because I follow Sophia Bush,"
and what's really incredible
about our ownership group,
when you think about
the power of Angel City,
is that each one of them
has their own audience,
and each one of them are
sharing things about us
and aligning with us on things
that they're passionate about.
And the expectation,
when they invested in Angel City,
was you have to care about the purpose
and you have to be available to help us,
you know, grow the business,
and have a positive
impact on our community,
and everybody signed up for that.
But beyond passion for owners,
for more money to continue
to flow into women's sports,
it's going to need more evidence
that it can be successful,
and, for investors, that means data.
Everyone's heard of the money ball effect.
You know, we're increasingly using data
to help our players get the
most out of their careers,
out of their performance,
and, on the business side of sports,
unfortunately, there's been a lot of just,
"Hey, that's how we've
always done business."
Angela Ruggiero has played more games
in a USA hockey Jersey
than any man or woman,
winning gold, silver, and bronze medals.
After her career on the ice,
she got an MBA at Harvard
and set up Sports Innovation Lab.
It's a Boston based company
that uses data science
to help teams and leagues
understand their fans
and figure out how to better engage them,
and, to be clear, to
help them find new ways
to make revenue off them.
We watch sports differently.
I watch sports differently.
Half the time, I have my
second screen in my hand,
I'm flipping through scores,
checking out highlights, got my red zone,
maybe I'm on Twitch over here.
Where we're doing things very differently.
We're all shifting in how we consume,
contribute to sports, create content,
interact with athletes,
model shifting overnight.
In the early days of the sports industry,
you had a very localized fan,
so ticket sales were really
the biggest proponent of revenue.
Then, as you start to move
into the 1940s and 50s,
you have the advent of broadcast media
that allows for fans to start
following more than just their local team,
and that also starts to translate
into them becoming more
consumers of sports,
so they start buying.
You start seeing merchandising
and sponsorship opportunities
start to really take off.
And now what we've really moved into
in this digital age,
with the advent of the internet,
of smartphones, of social media,
we're moving into what we
call the age of the fluid fan.
And they believe that,
just as the advent of television
helped fuel new areas of revenue
in the age of the global fan,
new technology and social platforms
will do the same in the
age of the fluid fan.
We see an evolving media landscape
where all fans want
more than just the game.
Now they want more online,
they wanna understand the athletes,
they want that Netflix docuseries,
but fans of women's sports,
per the fan project data,
suggests that they want it more.
In a report published earlier this year,
SIL outlines how fans of women's sports
are ahead of the curve
when it comes to how
technology is changing fandom.
You can't be a lazy women's sports fan.
You can't just turn on the game,
you can't just find your
content wherever you want.
We've almost forced
the hand of this market
to be digitally savvy.
We forced the hand of this market
to behave in ways, maybe
they were uncomfortable,
but they got over that hurdle
and they were the first to do it.
What that gives us is
this incredible group
of what we call early adopters,
and this has been used in
other industries before.
Sometimes, they're called hyper users.
When I was at Spotify, we
called them trendsetters,
but essentially, what
you need to understand
about early adopters
is that, typically,
they will only represent
one to 10% of a given fan base.
They can represent as much as 50 to 80%
of the revenue potential
that you can drive.
And while there's
potentially a lot of money
to be made in understanding
the behavior of women's sports fans,
the report also made clear
there's a big opportunity in
women's sports themselves.
In our analysis,
we looked at a number of sources
that predicted the global
sports business market
would be around 800 billion by 2030.
We believe, if we invest
in women's sports now,
the opportunity for women's sports
could be a third of that
$800 billion market.
In its report, SIL proposes
what it calls a community-based
monetization model.
It outlines how women's sports
can capitalize on this
shifting fan behavior
by producing more story-driven content,
distributing it on new,
emerging platforms,
and measuring quality of
engagement over quantity.
You have to approach this market
with a focus on it's a different fan.
Don't just take the same
model, do it differently,
build out your revenue in new ways,
and that actually is gonna
unlock, in our opinion,
not just a better ROI, better return,
but also it's where the puck is headed,
if I can use a hockey analogy.
You've actually created a
market of your future consumer.
That's your current fan of women's sports.
They're already there.
Angel City won't play any games here
at Bank of California Stadium
until the spring of 2022,
and while they have good financial backing
and have made early sponsorship deals,
they're still going to
need to attract fans,
and the best path to that
is through their players.
We think fandom has really changed,
and it's changed, mostly,
because of social media,
where I'm a fan of the player first,
their team second, and
then the league third,
and so, when you think about the asset
that is most valuable to you
being your 22, 24 person roster,
the way that I can create a
connection with that player
that can then translate to the club
and then allow us the ability to monetize
is to tell the story
of who that player is.
Good morning, Angel City fans.
I am so excited to be coming home.
I hope to see you soon!
And, for Angel City,
they needed a star,
and it's hard to find a better option
than LA's own Christen Press.
And Press, there it is!
The moment they've been waiting for!
A native of Southern California,
she's Angel City's first
and currently only player on the roster,
and before Angel City plays
any games on the pitch,
they'll rely on Press
to help build awareness.
That's especially important for a new team
in a nine-year-old circuit
that's the third try
at a US pro women's soccer league.
I may not know there's an NWSL.
I may not know there's a
national women's soccer league,
but I know there's an Alex Morgan,
I know Megan Rapinoe,
I know Christen press,
and when I start to follow them,
then I find out,
Oh, wait, they play for the Orlando Pride,
or they are soon to play for Angel City.
Angel City will need a roster
full of name recognition like Press
to drive interest to their team.
That has been the theory on
the NWSL from its inception,
to connect the popularity
and historic success
of the US Women's National Team
to a more traditional league.
But at a time when player
trust in that league
is being challenged,
Angel City is attempting
to help provide support
for all women's soccer players,
both future and past.
They've been producing a profile series
around young talent in the LA area,
and recently announced a
plan to create a players fund
so the retiring professional players
can receive money for education
in their post-career life.
There is a huge gap right now
from the time that you retire
to the time that you are entering
into your next career path,
so that's one of the things
and ways that we like to
think about player care,
is, you know, looking at
that player holistically,
and it's not just about the time
that they're playing in the
league, but it's, you know,
what are they doing afterwards,
and how can we help to foster and connect
that community as well?
It's an acknowledgement
that while the early returns
look good for Angel City,
this is a long-term
investment in the sport,
and that they're committed, not only,
to fielding a successful team,
but building a successful
sports ecosystem.
One that goes beyond their team
or even the current league.
Our aspiration is to be a global brand,
and it's been our aspiration from day one,
and the reason is, because,
if you're a global brand,
you could have the most impact.
Full-stop.
It's a platform that stands
for equality and impact,
and if we can develop a
relationship with our community
that goes way beyond wins and losses,
we have the ability to impact their lives.
The future of the NWSL
may remain in question for some time,
but it's clear from the
outpouring of support from fans
that they intend to support the players
wherever they ultimately play,
and it's never been more
clear that who funds,
and, ultimately, who
profits from women's sports
have the opportunity
to make big changes in,
not just sports, but society.
Yes, women's sports is
the right thing to do.
Yes, we should be investing in women.
We should be creating role
models for all of society.
Yes, check, check, check,
but there's more than that.
Women's sports is actually a big business.
It's unlocking revenue,
it's unlocking potential understanding
of where fandom in general is going,
but you have an opportunity to get in now
with women's sports.
And, from an investment perspective,
it's one of the biggest differences
between men's and women's sports.
For the most popular sports in the world,
to buy into a team in the men's space
is maybe one of the
hardest deals to close,
but, for those same sports,
the women's game is open for business.